the chargers no longer have philip
rivers at quarterback they are creating
the impression that tyrod taylor is
their guy but coach anthony lin speaking
with reporters on wednesday
made it clear that he's casting a wide
net chris said anthony lynn i'm very
familiar with tyrod taylor i would say
right now he's in the driver's seat but
no position is finalized until we get to
training camp cam newton's a good
quarterback he's had some injuries but
if he's healthy he'll be a good
quarterback for somebody we're looking
at everybody man i want to turn over
every single rock so yeah we're looking
at
everybody so hey that doesn't mean
they're just handing the ball to tyrod
taylor earlier this week we suggested
that colin coward who's got ties to the
chargers organization was in their draft
room two years ago when he says that cam
newton and tyrod taylor are the same guy
it feels like he's carrying water for
the chargers for them to not
pursue cam newton and to stick with
tyrod taylor based on what he's saying
did i hear colin cowherd challenge you a
little bit on what you said
here's what he did here's what he did my
point was
he's been in the chargers draft room
he's clearly got connections to the team
and when he comes out with the
ridiculous assertion that cam newton and
tyrod taylor are the same guy he is
spreading the idea that the chargers
don't want cam they want tyrod and he's
defending them in advance for taking
tyrod and i said oh by the way a couple
of weeks ago the chargers handed him the
scoop that the tampa bay buccaneers
would get tom brady's services not the
chargers and when he was on air later
that day he pushed only on that the
question of whether or not he got the
tom brady scoop from the chargers didn't
address anything else and frankly if you
don't address the rest of it if you
don't say anything about the rest of it
you got nothing to say about the rest of
it and he also said that he talked to
tom telesco the gm of the chargers
after he broke the news that brady was
going to the buccaneers so reinforcing
the idea that there's communication
there there's a relationship there my
point is you're not making this
ridiculous claim that tyrod taylor and
cam newton are the same guy uh in a
vacuum especially if you've got contacts
with the charges and it tells me the
charges at least for now are airing on
the side of tyrod taylor but lynn's
comments changed that chris
lin's comments make that clear that
they at least are willing to consider
him and i think the real impediment
continues to be his health
yeah i think so now i again i'll say
this i understand them wanting to play
with ty rod taylor anthony lin has a
little history with him i think anthony
lin wants to play a style of football
where he runs the ball he's a little
more conservative in the past game i
think he's been scarred by phillip
rivers the last few years their defense
is legit mike i mean it's one of the
best in football so i understand that
but what i also want to say is cam
newton is very capable of playing that
style of football i mean that's what he
did a lot of years in carolina and you
know cam newton i expect him to be fully
healthy i don't think he's going to have
a problem still being able to be a
threat to run the football especially
what i saw the other day and just to
work out how aggressively he was cutting
off his foot and dropping back and
things like that that went a long way to
make me feel better about it now here he
also left the door open for you know of
course them drafting a quarterback at
pick number seven right is that what
they're at pick seven or six sorry okay
so
you know this is where i just don't get
it what and i want to pose this question
to you mike like if you're going to go
with tyrod taylor right now and you have
this defense that's ready to win right
now
go all in with tyrod taylor go like
don't waste the number six pick on a
quarterback like get a difference maker
to help your team and then the top of
the second round get a beast running
back to go along with austin eckler and
play that style of football but to me if
you draft the quarterback you know i
don't know tom telesco you know anthony
lynn are you gonna be there next year if
you guys go eight and eight or seven and
nine i'm not sure so i think that's
risky too to draft the quarterback early
and that's why i say go cam newton if
he's healthy because now you can build
the team and not have to worry about oh
our future quarterback and that's to me
the advantage they have there and i
think that's an intriguing conversation
i don't get this stubborn refusal to
recognize that they are the los angeles
chargers not the san diego chargers not
the san antonio chargers not the saint
louis chargers they are the los angeles
chargers when in rome baby they do not
embrace the idea that this is a venue
this is a city this is a sports town
that wants sizzle with its steak there's
no sizzle with tyrod taylor the sizzle
is with cam newton and really if they're
the same guy
all the more reason to go get newton
because newton's going to put butts in
the seats newton's going to sell jerseys
there hasn't been a guy in the history
of the franchise worth of crap that's
worn number one can you imagine that
chargers number one jersey with newton
on the back that is the way that you
need to think if you want to be a
successful football business operation
and there's a way to sell it from a
football standpoint and maybe they
definitely might maybe they're just
being maybe they're being careful maybe
they're being hesitant maybe they don't
want to get burned they don't want to
commit millions to a guy who shows up
and
he can't play because those videos don't
show what a guy really is able to do
when it's time to put the pads on and go
out there but my god i'd try to be
getting at the front of the line i don't
know if they're being coy to keep other
teams from waking up to cam newton i
don't get it but if they want to thrive
in la not just survive and they're
having a hard time surviving cam newton
it's a no-brainer i mean if i can see it
they should be able to see it cam newton
is the guy that they should want it
makes too much sense to not happen
yeah well all right and you know you
know okay you know the contract
situation with cam there's in that what
do you sign him to yeah it'd be a
short-term contract yeah he's gonna have
to prove he could stay healthy and that
he could still play we get that one year
two-year deal maybe with a one-year
option whatever it may be but mike i
agree with you a hundred percent and to
this fact again i don't want to sound
negative on tyrod taylor i don't you can
win football games with him you saw him
go to the playoffs before my play games
with him are you gonna win playoff games
with him i i don't think you're gonna
win many you might win one you're gonna
have to win them in a certain way and i
think it's it's hard to win that certain
way uh in this day and age in the nfl so
you're right i don't know if i feel real
confident about i think they can get to
the playoffs do i think they can make a
playoff run with tyrod taylor i would
probably say no and that's my point
exactly cam newton he's an organization
changer he's a oh man we oh did you see
our quarterback get off the bus we got a
chance to win today look i mean look at
this big sucker out here in pre-game war
maps he'll give the whole team
confidence in the locker room no matter
who they play you're playing the chiefs
oh we don't give a damn we got cam
newton in a good defense here we come
today oh we're playing you know who
another top team in the and then the afc
or whatever it may be
cam newton is a game changer that way
and then mike i mean do you hear my
point too if you're going to go with ty
rod taylor i'm just saying yeah don't wh
why draft the quarterback that's you
know what i mean like go all in try to
win you know i just again i don't know
are you gonna be there are you safe do
you maybe they know something we don't
know but i would just be worried if we
go seven to nine or eight and eight
again and we drafted a quarterback in
number six man the next regime might get
the benefits of that quarterback we
might not even be able to get to see him
play unless there's a guy that you're
convinced is going to be a hall of fame
talent at quarterback i would not draft
a quarterback until i've bottomed out
and i am clearly in rebuilding mode
especially this year right there are too
many other quarterbacks available that
you can plug into your offense
don't go all in for a rookie quarterback
if you think you have a chance to go all
in to be a competitive team and maybe
get back to the postseason and maybe
make some yeah i think that
yeah i agree with you don't you think
that don't you think they're close right
i mean we see their defense yeah they
got mike williams a receiver keane and
allen hunter henry at tight end they're
improving their offensive line we know
the defense is good during what james
wasn't even healthy last year you know
they just got chris harris jr you know
to me yes if this is the route you want
to go i just don't even i would say
don't don't waste the pick on the on the
quarterback at number six go with the
guys you got and then that's that's why
i'd go with cam newton to what you're
saying and then go cam newton and then
you could feel better about wasting that
number six pick on building your
football team and then that pick at the
top of the second round to further build
your football team
there just seems to be a failure to
recognize within the chargers
organization that they're in los angeles
and
and and and the one way to cure this
problem of walking out into your stadium
and seeing 80
there rooting for the opposing team is
to connect with la the rams have been
kicking their butts in that regard and
they don't even seem to notice and they
don't even seem to care and if they want
to make us think they care they should
go get cam
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports